hey guys today it is the 16th of much my
name is Jess and you are watching games
what news the newest GTA online update
is out now and not only has it brought
along a bunch of new cars and the sumo
wrestling mode it's also implemented a
bunch of functionality fixes the March
15 patch notes described a bunch of new
fixes which should improve general game
stability and network performance rock
stars also made tweaks to allow for
faster load times both when joining
sessions and moving between sessions
this is a particularly exciting change
given GTA online load times can be
pretty excruciating the patch notes also
suggests that Rockstar have addressed a
number of equally important issues
including but not limited to quote an
issue that was causing prostitutes to
not charge any money for their services
you can read the full set of patch notes
in our story on games plans gears of war
floor produced a rod fergusson has
cleared up the fact that while the next
game in the series will be darker it is
not going to be survival horror a bunch
of creepy gears images / twitter user
Timothy penny well to ask if gears fall
was going to be a horror game to which
Ferguson replied Noah when not survival
horror we just wanted to darker tone
with still an action game the game's
initial reveal mostly showed atmospheric
set pieces set in an abandoned mansion
and castle in August of last year
Ferguson said Gears of War for was
aiming to tell a more intimate personal
and morally ambiguous narrative than
what they've attempted in earlier games
the game's story will take place over
the span of 24 hours and the coop will
be limited to two players as opposed to
four in Gears of War 3 a multiplayer
beta is being held in April and the full
game is Judas for finally sony has
confirmed that all existing PlayStation
4 games will be playable in PlayStation
VR using a cinema mode the mode
simulates a five-metre screen within a
virtual space so yes that means you'll
be in your living room while in a
virtual reality living room virtually
playing a game so
added users will also be able to enjoy
360-degree photos and videos that are
captured by devices such as omni
directional cameras on PS VR buy a ps4
media player which will let them feel as
if they are physically inside the
captured seen as for custom built for VR
games sony have said 230 devs are on
board to develop PS VR games with 160
projects currently in development the
SVR will be out in October of this year
for 400 bucks in North America the
device also requires the purchase of a
PlayStation camera which isn't included
in the package let me know down in the
comments section what you think of the
PSP our cinematic mode be shuttered game
slot or we've got stories on oculus rift
and a brand new doom trailer that is
everything I have you today we should
let me know what you thought of today's
stories and I will see you again
tomorrow